logic to make lots of money logical  selling which is like let's just talk  through this  and if it makes sense let's do it if it  doesn't no worries what are the things  what are the frameworks we think about  to get to yes right and the yes that i  want from somebody is not a yes i'm  going to buy  but yes i'm going to decide  because my goal is to give this person  power  who here  wants to be powerful  power is neutral  you can be incredibly powerful and bad  incredibly powerful and good and so the  idea is if we can harness power then it  amplifies who we are  and if we're shitty people then we're  very very shitty people and we're very  good we're very very good and if we can  do that for our prospects we can allow  them to step into the person they want  to be and make a decision to own their  ship one way or another that make sense